[Music]
what Hollywood is becoming central
Africa's Hollywood Isaac navona has shot
action films for the past seven years on
almost no budget in waka Liga a slum in
Uganda's capital Kampala now a
television station has asked him to
produce a 13-part series the
professionals have high standards karna
Bwana a self-taught filmmaker
meet those standards
[Music]
they're a team and they have a ritual
every day before shooting starts this is
the the script we are following for
today shooting on the agenda today a
fast-paced chase with guns motorbikes
and house-to-house fighting the director
wants the weapons to be used effectively
and to make sure they're visible
powerful and threatening because this it
means you maybe you are running away but
with this you are looking for something
because it is done and you were your
eyes now are showing after two hours
they're ready to go it's going to be
actually in the ghetto the shooting
location is right around the corner on
the street in front of his house
this is where Isaac navona grew up he's
44 now and has lived here since his bow
he doesn't have to ask for a filming
permit everyone here knows him his
family once owned this derelict house he
choreographs the fight on the spot his
actors belong to Uganda's national
kung-fu team i said 'no Bwana has only
one camera so he often has to shoot
scenes more than once the actors know
and fear his ambitious use of unusual
camera angles even if I am satisfied
I've tried to find to find out if they
can do better than even better so I
always I'm always looking for something
excellent
so that's why sometimes look like I'm
dissatisfied but sometimes I'm okay
sometimes okay I don't show them that
I'm already done but I want something
better what special about Isaac
Nirvana's films is that he often casts
women as his action heroes three months
ago
Rita nobuta B couldn't do a single
combat kick we train from here or come
here in the morning and train on
Thursday Saturday and Sandy so that's
how I gained that third training from
here but I didn't get any FISC addition
we must go to train from here at work
early
boo-ki the TV one of Uganda's most
successful broadcasters is in a more
well-heeled district of Kampala James
sarin Kumar is the station manager he
convinced Isaac Nibbana to make a 13
episode TV series for the station sarin
Toma is in constant contact with what
Hollywood keeping track of what Nibbana
is filming and to me what is most
important is the content before I look
at that faith's before I look at what is
the story flowing is the content in it
good that is my major concern bouquet
the TV still doesn't know if the first
episodes will be ready in time for the
holidays but they're already planning
the publicity campaign this is going to
be here this side it's going to be here
is going to come during our breakfast
show we'll invite him and he talks about
it so then he will be able to explain
what is in the film how does he do it
what should people expect I expect and
you know like will they also give chance
to the audience for calling and asking
questions
Isaac Nirvana is under pressure right
after shooting he rushes to the editing
suite trying to finish sequence after
sequence the main thing is action I love
action so I feel like if the whole movie
could be action that could be a most
important thing for me I hate dialogues
even when I'm editing dialogues they are
boring but if it is action then you see
some life
his wife Harriet is on hand for every
shoot Nevada has never tackled a project
as big as this one
I've been trusted by you know book head
there and in vision group so I have to
keep that's why I do everything myself i
said 'no bwana
thinks it's all taking too long
[Music]
but his wife wants the makeup to be
perfect
after almost two hours
Apollo assim way has become a bad guy
when shooting starts real bodyguards
appear they're met to make sure there's
no trouble a few metres away
doubt abuse ah so who's in charge of
props is lighting a fire the rubber
pistols have to look real with the right
gunshot residue then it's all action the
series tells a classic story of good and
evil police versus gangsters plus
abduction and power but more than
anything plenty of action
a bit later there's a surprise
James Aaron Kumar from Phuket ATV
appears on the set
he's worried about his deadline and he
wants what Hollywood to deliver the
first episodes I would like to tell you
is that we are we are trying to to
finish in time as as you are you asked
to have at least the five episodes in
the festive season or done but they're
not yet done but at least we are we are
all now meaning with that lists may be
in the middle the big part but we are
still you know you know action is
different it's not like love stories of
what you like what you can Street me in
a week at least and say okay let me edit
in the other week but with action you
you you film and then you give you
lyrics like two days or what something
because these actors are exhausted and
then somehow injured something like that
it's also because nobody here gets
properly paid the actors are their money
by selling DVDs of the film's stay
focused don't you know get derailed
because of course now I know you are
starts already within this promotion you
are celebrities but don't get ready on
this you continue being focused continue
doing this good work because with work I
would as far as I'm seen the sky is the
limit
[Applause]
Jamis Arun Kumar demands to see the
footage until now Isaac Madonna has only
delivered a rough summary of the
contents and has refused all the TV
professional support
I think this is very good but what I
would request you to do these at leasts
make me the one mint flavor for me to
take to cook a bit and then I start
promoting it I intend to run this during
Christmas period promotion is also a new
duty for Isaac mob wanna sarin Kumar has
brought along his own film crew the PR
machine is up and running
documenting the visit to what Hollywood
the man from the television station is
now convinced that he's bought the right
product especially because of the women
on screen something completely new for
Uganda we are jumping over and you know
shooting dance
[Music]
to do that Isaac Makwana has to shoot
new footage there's almost no time limit
it is a challenging and for me I always
believe in the challenges yeah I want to
challenge this okay okay
okay thank you and bye-bye nice hey the
last sequence of the day the Sun is
about to set and the scene has to be in
the Canon as soon as possible I said 'no
Bwana now knows he'll make it and when
the first episode is running on TV he'll
already be shouting action again for
what he loves
for what Kollywood